hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to solitude with someone
walking by my window over there I don't
take nothing too kindly to that because
I'm a solitary person listening to music
read my emails hi
yesterday it was really cool but do not
expect anything else you scare me
you are a freak that cannot be changed
I'm not ready to live my life with such
a hermit your problems are disgusting
and pointless they're only yours not
mine best wishes to Nami
what you just said yesterday was really
cool why do you gotta go through the
hold and the rest of the email insulting
me well this is off to a flying start my
goodness well I'm really sad that I
opened that particular email oh man is
this about the story of someone who has
like social anxiety or something like
that and they actually can't get out oh
that's weird
that's trippy okay then that's
fascinating if it is I don't know I
literally one minute into this game and
I'm already trying to get a meaning to
this why not get some sunlight it's a
beautiful day with a weird political
sudden going on out there but I don't
know what else do we have
it's got to be something else right read
the diary 6 of June I think I will not
leave this room anymore
yesterday I had a wonderful night with
that guy but after all I bored him with
all my fears and insecurities he left
and will not come back I'm hurt and
scared he doesn't need me like this no
one needs I cannot change I will spend
some more decades here and after that
all that's left for me is just a fetid
black spot I want to see him again well
you're not gonna be able to see him
again if you're stuck in that room
that's so weird but then again if that's
the guy that you want to go out on a
date with that guy's an [ __ ] that
guy's a dick bag and I'm pretty sure you
could do better than that
least you're eating healthy and there's
got to be something else to this right
can't just be about this grab throw
huh oh I've got a picture of a guy face
palming well that's good is my wine for
my solitary adventure oh man
this game is getting more and more
depressing by the second oh I hope those
are condoms if they're not then they're
priceless rubes okay
oh geez I don't need to wreck up my room
why's there crack in the wall huh can I
throw something got that in no that
didn't work well that didn't work either
yeah well I've got the magic teleporting
oh well that's lovely this is just
lovely oh that's my closet oh no it's my
walkway attention before leading
consider this food can be bought online
toilet and bathroom are overestimated by
our society bathroom is down the
corridor on the left
you don't need work you have parents and
Welfare real people are irrelevant go
surf some social networks who wrote this
No
did you write this note for yourself no
you got to get out there in the public
live life love life to live love life I
don't know what else I'm gonna throw if
I'm just gonna mess up I put on my
fedora ah yes now I feel like me let me
put on my other fedora ah yes oh now I
am a true gentleman and I may be lady
don't leave the room that's really
creepy
you know I open this door expecting
there to be maybe a hallway in an
apartment complex and still I got an
insulting message and a ominous warning
so um okay was that I want to sleep no I
don't know no I don't know I know I
don't that that message is not getting
any closer
I have to stay no no I don't know no
nobody loves me I love me and that's all
that matters I must study well that's
probably important that's not for me I
am too lonely I must study want to stay
home jeez oh jeez oh jeez I am out in an
ocean of darkness what if I say
something stew
big don't say that don't say that
definitely oh I only hope this is where
I'm supposed to go because otherwise I
am going to be lost
[Music]
now reach the world with you now
oh geez can you stop the Gregorian chant
in my ears okay I don't know where I'm
going right now but this is so weird so
weird what do I do I'm so lonely I'd
rather nobody waits for me there will be
people I'd rather stay in my room man
what do I do
I've walked all that way I have to close
the door I'm too ugly wait
I have to close the door tonight is that
why I didn't let me go through cuz I
forgot to close the door well let me
just go on my way then close this door
yeah I closed it I did it and I'm free
yeah
Abbi oh me oh my oh me oh my oh I'm so
angry man oh sorry about this Suzy throw
what do you want from me I don't know
what you want oh this might be maybe no
whoa what was that
I thought I saw something I didn't see
anything okay wait a minute I have an
idea
[Music]
get out of my life hello how are you -
diary get out of my life
what did this note say down the corridor
to the left I don't have a corridor out
there I don't have anything you're
ruining my life
okay hang on this might be it well this
might be a thing but what happens if I
throw everything out
[Music]
no come on throw I was almost correct in
putting on my fedora
wear a coat I didn't know I could wear a
coat nice I'm wearing a coat can I wear
a hat I've kind of threw out everything
else I don't think this is how I was
supposed to be yeah sure is convenient
so throw the trash what what is that oh
that's my phone [ __ ] you phone me get
out of here you two get out of here get
all the way out there
oh don't sass me bro stool though this
tool can go grab these condoms just
something tells me this probably isn't
the correct answer something tells me
that I may have just ruined my entire
apartment by trying to throw everything
away well goddamn it I won't be thwarted
I did put on a coat though so that's
nice okay and with this last book
I have officially thrown out every
single gosh darn thing in this room out
into the black void of the abyss but I
can't find anything else even remotely
close to what I'm supposed to be doing I
did a lot of cleaning and it looks
lovely and barren but I don't know if
there's anything else that I'm actually
supposed to be doing there's this
mysterious crack in the wall help me at
all so honestly I have no idea if the
game is only supposed to be an idea
about the feeling of isolation and more
of an emotive game than anything but I
want to find out I'm gonna go look up to
see if I can find out if there is an
ending first before I call this one
because I really want to know why
why in the fatback can I leave the room
okay so I cannot seem to figure it out
and I looked up and apparently no one
else has either the developer isn't even
saying if there is an end of the game
even though there are trophies or
achievements for finally finding freedom
I don't understand how that's possibly
done so what I'll take from this is more
of an
interpretive style of like what it means
to have social anxiety and want to be
alone all the time or not even want to
be alone but be forced to by your own
emotions so that's the only
interpretation that I can take out of
the game but I hope you enjoyed
nonetheless because it's so fascinating
to see like these artistic games it's
interesting and in a sense I feel like
this could be fleshed out a lot more and
I think the developer is actually going
to flesh it out a lot more but I feel
like it's on the right path the
exploration and just kind of like
putting you in the shoes of someone who
is this way and they're unapologetically
that way that is just who they are and
it is what it is but either way that's
all the time I got for this video I'm
not gonna keep trying at this one so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye